do you have any creative regrets like a
film idea not followed well I think my
biggest regret would be not making the
movie I'm trying to make right now
I mean search and rescue is a movie
that's like been percolating for at
least seven or eight years if not longer
it's a movie that I I feel like I should
have made a long time ago but I was sort
of not sort of I was scared for a lot of
reasons I didn't think I didn't think I
could handle another disappointment if
it didn't happen because obviously
anybody's been you know like John Baum I
remember I heard John Boorman say
something once it was really interesting
and I totally got it
he said he said in a very bitter moment
he said this business is all about the
movies you didn't get to make and I was
like really you made like a lot of
really cool you mean deliverance in
Excalibur and all the help and glory
you're being bitter but for every
filmmaker there are all those pictures
that didn't happen which is the nature
of the thing but in the case of search
and rescue that's a movie that I always
knew was going to be independent I knew
that the movie couldn't really be
produced
traditionally anyway which is perfect
cuz I so fed up with the way Hollywood
works anyway and and and I realized that
this was something that I had to do
truly independently but it took me a
while to muster up the courage to to do
it and so I think my biggest regret
would be if I didn't follow through with
this movie which now we're in the you
know in the early early stages of it but
that's that's that's my I don't think
it's a fear it's just I it's put you
know my I'm pushing myself from behind
to make this thing happen so I don't
have those regrets why now though I
think it's you know I think it goes back
to to what you were talking about about
where I am timing wise in my life I mean
I feel like this is the right time for
me to make this kind of movie for me I
just reached a stage and it's been
several years now where I felt like the
movies I were I was making for hire just
were not it just wasn't just didn't sit
right with me and just I felt like I was
spinning wheels or worse wasting my time
I just felt like yeah I can make a
shitty sci-fi movie but that's what it
is
and it does you know I've said this tie
thing qui talked about this before I
think all filmmakers are our heroin
addicts in a way
not literally ill - some are in the
sense that your junkie for just a just
the process of making a film so it's
hard enough to get anything made so even
if somebody says we're gonna offer you
three bucks to make a movie for a sci-fi
channel do you want to do it my first
instinct was always like yes because it
was that needle in the arm like we can
make a movie but the the box that those
movies gets gets made and only allows
for a certain type of movie to result no
matter what you do I always have this
delusion that I'm gonna bring I'll be
able to bring something more tanned then
what is usually expected of you know a
low-budget exploitation movie and in the
end there may be little hits here and
there of individuality and maybe a pinch
more intelligence but in the end it is
what it is
so then you spent an enormous amount of
time and energy on something that is
essentially inconsequential unless
unless I was happy being that but I
always felt like I was wrestling with
identity issues like what did I want to
be did I want to be a professional
Hollywood director and did I want that
or did I also want to be somebody who
made movies that mattered to me
personally and I when I when I really
did the math and I looked at the
different films that I've had the good
fortune to be able to make over the
years you know good or bad I looked at
him and I going you know I was most
satisfied when I was making I was most
myself when I was making these really
small movies where I didn't really have
to deal with the of Hollywood
or people telling me to recut it or cut
this storyline or or put this music in
or whatever and nobody monkeyed with it
and even though I wasn't getting paid
anything sometimes that was where I felt
like I was at home creatively
so you know I got to a point where I
felt like this is where this is where I
need to be if I'm gonna be honest with
myself or I can keep pulling myself in
these different directions and allowing
myself to say yeah if I make this other
thing you know it's just it's okay it's
good you know but it was a part of me
that was telling me you know you he kind
of got to go back to your early ideas
your early films and that's where you
were happiest right I did have a really
good spike with some guy who kills
people that was like an accident you
know where this like present dropped out
of the sky the timing was just you know
was just like one of those things where
if you stay at the slot-machine long
enough something good will happen
well something managed to drop that I
happened to connect with and that was
like I was a super lucky to get that job
but I didn't create that you know what I
mean I didn't I didn't self create that
that was just it was just really perfect
timing and I can't I can't allow myself
to just hope that something else is
gonna drop from the sky
I gotta kind of put it on the line and
then make the thing myself
you know we talked about the addiction
part and and you know I've probably
mentioned this a gazillion times in film
courage interviews but um it'sit's the
subject of like your levels are blown
out so so the filmmaker Sebastian Junger
he made Restrepo with Tim Heather right
and he talked about men that go to
battle yeah sometimes they keep going
back because going to the family
barbecue like the level of the
adrenaline rush that you're used to is
no longer there laughs your levels are
blown out so I would imagine that's
similar for someone who's been on stage
doing stand-up or music and filmmaking
as well I agree I think that it's like
you know you've gotten this taste of a
certain energy when you make a film even
if you've only made one film even if
you've just made a short you know I tell
this to my students if you make a
student film and you get this brush that
you've never felt before and you really
want that rush again and that's what
motivates you then you know you're a
real filmmaker and if you can get that
rush anywhere else then please do it
because it's so much
easier so I think that when you've made
a few films and you know what that hai
is then you crave that hi and it's very
difficult to just be satisfied with not
making a film I mean I think that's
really what it boils down to it's like
most filmmakers are not satisfied when
they're not making a film so you spend a
lot of time in between hustling to try
to find a way to get to that that high
again just like a soldier who you know
mysteriously - it - and I'm objectively
it sounds crazy like why would you want
to go back but even if you listen to the
opening of Apocalypse Now the narration
is that you know as that stuff when I
was you know when I was here I wanted to
be there when I was home all I wanted to
be he was back in the jungle you know
and it's that sort of like you're it's a
heavy attraction or addiction
you